today in U.S okay a lot of people were
sitting there historically we've been
told when
a market crash happens or you know too
much of dollars being printed gold
prices go up nothing happened okay so
the gold Crusaders were like oh you're
gonna see what's gonna happen with gold
and Gold's gonna go to 5 000. okay all
right sounds good why if you look at the
numbers with gold anytime we've done
this Gold's gone up it's time for the
golden version we print a 40 American
money we print analyzed we've never done
this before okay fine sounds good the
crypto Community says well let me tell
you decentralized people have been
asking for decentralized we have it here
right and it's decentralized and the
reality of crypto is the fact that you
know it's different than everything else
where recently a paper came out if you
can zoom in here shown that Bitcoin has
been trading with the stock market this
year so for the Bitcoin Community that's
pitching the fact that if the stock
market goes down Bitcoin goes up or
whatever you know it's not the same I'm
sorry if you go a little lower to show
the data go a little lower if you show
the data right there golden Lord to the
second paragraph uh the data right their
shows of the 98 trading days we've had
so far Bitcoin and S P 500 Index have
moved in the same exact Direction 73 of
them while moving in the opposite only
25 times so is there anything unique
about Bitcoin compared to the stock
market or is Bitcoin just now a digital
gold it's just another stock right so
okay so we were thinking Bitcoin if the
market was going to tank and we're going
to print money Bitcoin is going to go to
100 200 000 nope it's at 29 000 today
okay well if you if we increase interest
rates and Powell's going to increase
interest rates that means inflation is
not going to go up and it's going to
stay at around four or five percent nope
it's at eight and a half percent and we
keep increasing interest rates and yeah
but if we increase interest rates you
know real estate value is going to take
ahead and go but okay so out of all the
things that we're looking at today
what are the main data we ought to look
at to say listen we know the definition
of a a recession is two quarters in a
row right it's it's the numbers two
quarters in a row when uh Cove would
happen and the market dropped what 50 or
40 in the span of a month it came back
up that's not a recession that's a
market crash okay it's got to be two
quarters you know fine we know that
what are some of the most concerning
data that you see in America today
that you're sitting there saying things
are not going to be good and if it's
something where you are saying things
are not going to be good how bad are
things going to be in the U.S economy
the next 12 24 36 60 months
okay well
there's a good comparison and that is
2008.
and and then you know what happened
since 2020. in 2008 we had essentially a
bubble collapsing that was more similar
to the Japanese situation so the banks
were creating a lot of credit
um that was used for
um property but also various financial
instruments so you had your asset price
surge
and once Bank credit suddenly tightened
which happened very dramatically
September 2008 and the banking system is
simply shut down
then the acid bubble collapses and we
saw that
um now at that time the Federal Reserve
acted very quickly in fact among
internationally among central banks it
was the one that reacted fastest and
also in the in the in the most proactive
way
um but the key thing is Bank credit
shrank after that for you know for a
year Bank credit just did not expand and
that's the biggest part that's the money
supply
the reserve stepped in it created a lot
of credit on its own a lot of people
said that this would create inflation
now and the dollar would collapse
because look what the FED is doing
I was one of the few who were saying no
the the dollar is not going to collapse
and there's not going to be inflation
why because the FED is a small Cog and
and the big wheel is the banking system
and they're shrinking so the total money
supply was actually not expanding
despite the the FED being hyperactive
now the FED did Implement one of my
policy recommendations from the true
quantitative easing that I'd formulated
in 1995 which is
and my true definition of true
quantitative easing of course is to
increase Bank credit creation for the
real economy
how do you do that and there's some
steps
um that the central bank can can take to
to do this
um and one is to help the banks restore
their the problems on their balance
sheet which they didn't do in Japan for
a long time and I told them many times
in many Publications and you know my
book princes of the end was the number
one bestseller in Japan ahead of Harry
Potter for six weeks I was on the
Japanese media uh very regularly uh 2001
2002 2003
um I was invited by Parliament there was
advisory to various government
committees but they never the Central
Bank never did this whereas the FED in
um and you see at the time in the 1990s
when I was proposing this first from 95
onwards
um Ben Bernanke as academic was
participating in these debates about
Japan
and he
as a head of the FED did Implement one
of my key recommendations and that was
the only Central Bank in the world that
did that in 2008 he was the FED namely
he took away these non-performing assets
from the banks from the big Banks very
quickly
by simply and this was my recommendation
by Simply Having the Central Bank buy
them up
of course not at market value at
something you know 20 cents on a dollar
or higher much higher okay maybe not at
a higher why stressed assets right so
why though because the banks are special
they create the money supply and you
need them if you want an economic
recovery and while they're impaired you
could have a 20-year recession that's
what Japan demonstrated right
um and so my recommendation was the
Central Bank should go and buy these
non-performing assets let's say at face
value at 100 they're only worth 20 but
the Central Bank goes out and buys them
at 100. what happens the banks of course
are immediately restored I mean they're
more liquid than ever their balance
sheets are super strong they can now go
out and create credit to their normal
business and of course you should impose
some conditions you guys stop the bank
lending for the asset purchases give
give out loans for productive businesses
they didn't they didn't do it though
well that's what one could impose yeah
the FED didn't do that no
um but to how Banks increase lending
again if you get rid of the non-forming
as you buy them up
um that solves the problem there's no
tax money involved and there's no cost
to society and you might say well hang
on there could be two types of costs the
central bank now has the non-forming
assets that's cost isn't it yeah but the
central bank is a special institution
first of all it doesn't have to mark the
market
so you won't see this
um also
um it you know central banks are always
profitable because they create the money
supply or they that at the core of the
money supply process let's say
um so I mean that if you want central
banks to be profitable I mean you should
arrest all the central banks for insider
trading you know of course the central
bank will always be profitable so it's
not a problem that the central bank is
purchasing but actually they're not even
having any losses
why
if the Central Bank buys these
non-performing assets from the banks at
100 they're worth only 20. it is
possible to book this in the accounts of
the Central Bank as a loss of 80 but
that wouldn't reflect reality and
accounts should reflect reality as much
as possible what is reality what is the
true gain
or loss that the central bank has it
doesn't have a loss it has a gain of 20.
it owns something worth 20.
and what did you pay well the cost of
funding is zero to the central bank so
that's why you don't have to worry about
that it's again to the central bank to
buy anything but where's the money from
Central Bank coming from
you could say the Central Bank creates
it now that that will raise the red flag
for you to say well hang on there's
another cost inflation and that's where
we uh come full circle no this does not
increase inflation because
inflation can be created when the
central bank and the banking system
create and inject money into the
non-bank economy and they do this for
unproductive purposes they do this too
much you get inflation or asset
inflation right but this is not what
happens here what happens is a booking
exercise within the banking system the
central bank and the banks are together
the banking system and all we're saying
is oh the central bank is now going to
use its powers to clean up the balance
sheets of the banks that in itself
doesn't inject any money into the
non-bank economy and therefore cannot
lead to inflation there's not a single
dollar this is injected into the
non-bank sector as a result of this and
that's what happens so Bank credit
recovered after a year four five percent
six percent Bank credit growth America
was the first country to recover after
2008 crisis
um and actually you think it was the
right move
it was the right move if well I mean I
would have done it even better because
they should have imposed uh certain
rules we know when you bail out the
banks
um you have a lot of power and they
could have used this to say okay from
now on we're going to do this properly
they didn't do that secondly they could
have
um not favored the Big Bang so much they
really favored the big Banks and really
you should have done this you believe in
socialism
no I don't but it's a crisis you see I
believe in the principle of moral hazard
that is who is responsible for this for
this crisis it's the central bank they
should pay up and and end it it
shouldn't have happened in the first
place yeah but central banks is getting
money the more they put into it my
dollar goes lower so you're hurting me
no if you're doing that it's not
creating and you're delaying a time bomb
and now you're getting rid of this as a
capital I'm a capitalist I'm a
full-blown capitalist I believe in
capitalism well then we must abolish
central banks and I would agree we don't
need central banks but now that we have
them and they're creating asset bubbles
yeah but you're feeding them you're
feeding the machine though you're making
it uh you're delaying the time bomb for
the Next Generation that's pay the price
you see compared Japan and the US in
Japan the Central Bank didn't do this so
then we had a 20-year recession all
these suicides you mentioned that's the
result of the Central Bank let me ask
you a question if you see because the
Central Bank power is increased when
they have Boombastic I have a hard time
with this abolishes the boom bust cycle
can I push you back and you push me back
just push me back and what I'm saying so
okay so let's keep creating fake success
so the current people of power don't
take a lot of hit because God forbid the
too big to fail companies take a big kid
let's protect those guys and then you
get the average guy that's sitting there
saying well you you definitely believe
in capitalism but it's capitalism for
the poor and socialism for the rich
right let's protect the bigger and and
when a person gives me that argument I
sit down and I said you're partially
right because we keep doing this so so
okay so today let's go to today but I'm
not saying
um you know what we should do is this is
not success you know the central banks
have created the asset bubbles they
should then use the tools that they have
to quickly delete their mistakes that's
what I'm saying that's affecting me and
my generation but it's not you see if
the Central Bank does it in this way
there's no money creation there's no
inflation in fact that's the big
difference to today 2020. there's a
money creation where does the money go
to the bank if they're going to buy a 20
stock rather than Pennies on a dollar
they bid at a hundred dollars where do
they get the money to give it to the
bank
there's no money injected as a result of
this bailout say the FED through it's
made in Lane one two three you know
purchasing the non-forming assets of the
banks okay that in itself doesn't inject
a penny into the non-bank economy
because it's cleaning up the banking
sector it's an intra Bank transaction
you see in the inside the banking system
between the fed and the banks therefore
that in itself doesn't create money and
the proof is in the pudding you know the
there was no inflation as I as I was
saying most people were saying oh the
feds but that's not proof in the pudding
though I I I disagree because just
because there's no inflation right off
the bat the first year second year third
that doesn't mean it is not coming that
doesn't mean winter is coming all you
did is you delayed winter for 10 to 15
years okay and then severe winter is
coming then let me give you two more
examples please where this was done and
then I think you'll you'll get the point
that it is a limited measure for
emergency situations but it doesn't
actually create inflation therefore once
you are in this situation you should do
it but of course you should also see why
did the central banks get us here in the
first place and avoid that so the two
examples are
um Japan 1945
what was the state of the banking sector
well it was actually worse than in you
know
1989 1990 when the bubble burst it was
worse in in 1990 the non-performing
Assets in the bank system were 25 of the
bank balance sheets which is a lot
that is a lot it's anything more than 10
is enough to bankrupt the banks
but in 1945 the non-performing Assets in
the Japanese banking system were like
100 percent
because they had two types of assets
they had
um greater East Asian Prosperity Bonds
war bonds forced on the banks of a
country that just lost the second world
war and secondly forced lending to the
Munitions industry of Munitions
companies they were also bust many now
not even in Japan anymore because you
know Manchuria Korea Taiwan and not part
of Japan anymore after 45. so 100
non-performing assets fine now the bank
of Japan decided okay we've just been
defeated devastated the cities have been
eradicated a lot of you know incendiary
bombs
um Flat Earth here where there used to
be a city it's not a good moment to have
a banking crisis let's not have a
banking crisis they always have this
option so what are we going to do we
will purchase the non-performing assets
from the banks at face value it was
actually a bit less than face value but
these are details and that's what they
did and so there was so after the 1945
much bigger banking crisis
how long was the recession how long was
the period in which banks did not lend
to to businesses anymore only one year
then they revved up lending the economy
recovered you're doing well in the 1990s
when the non-performing asset problem in
the banking system was much smaller
um
how long did it take 20 years why
because they still had their
non-performing assets the banks
continued to be risk-averse they reduced
they did not increase Bank lending the
reason for the 20-year recession is very
simply look at bank credit to the
economy negative for 20 years that's why
there was no recovery it's because they
constantly had these non-performing
assets this obstacle on their balance
sheet second example
August 1914.
the United Kingdom of Great Britain and
Ireland declared war on Germany Austria
Austria and Hungarian Empire and the
Ottoman Empire the first world war had
begun
now the city of London Bankers came to
the government and the the treasury and
the bank of England said oh by the way
we're bankrupt now why what happened
well London already was the world's
Financial Center
so all the paper Securities traded
between Germany Austria Istanbul and so
on was going through London a lot of it
was going through London they were
holding what then was considered
irredeemable enemy paper and it was too
much value zero because of the war they
were bust what did the bank of England
do which just declared war the first
world war is beginning
um let's not have a banking crisis so
they purchased the non-performing assets
at face value
and by the way
um you can actually even make a profit
um with standard accounting out of this
as well so what I'm saying is that when
you
when you are in such a bad situation
created by the central banks and we
should hold them to account why we're
here but then they do have a
responsibility to get us out of this
in the quickest possible way without a
long recession without suicides by
business people as we saw in Japan
because of the recession because the
banks don't lend to them so more and
more firms go bust that can be avoided
and it is this obstacle called
non-performing assets on the bank
balance sheets and you can just take
them away at zero cost of the taxpayer
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]